Mattel's iconic Barbie doll is
celebrating her 60th birthday this year
yeah the Barbie doll is 60 years old and
true story and celebration of this
milestone a Hilton Hotel has transformed
one of their Suites into the ultimate
Barbie experience this is a real thing
yes yes you I don't know what that
reaction means that was the sound of a
pancake deflating well it's a it's it's
a real thing and they're now open for
bookings you can get this ultimate
Barbie suite if you want it and we are
the only show that has footage exclusive
footage of the newlywed couple that was
lucky enough to be the rooms very first
guests we have the footage take a look
are you ready for your ultimate Barbie
experience Yeah right
that is Barbie's dream camper but we've
seen exact specifications as her real
camper everything in this room is
completely authentic to Barbie's world
completely authentic completely
authentic have a great night
[Applause]
make your Barbie dreams come true at
Hilton tonight
you